[Música]
las provincias separatistas de lugans y
los territorios ucranianos controlados
por Moscú de zaporilla y jerson votan en
referendos de anexión a Rusia en
zaporiya este sábado hubo bombardeos en
medio de los comicios
en Irán ya son 700 las personas
detenidas en las protestas por la muerte
de maxa
Human right watch habla de 50 muertos y
el ejército advierte que podría
intervenir a Minnie murió bajo custodia
policial tras ser detenida por la
policía de la moral
el ministro de exteriores de Rusia
serguéi labroz defendió la invasión de
Ucrania ante la asamblea general de las
Naciones Unidas Mientras que el
encargado de la diplomacia de China
wangie condenó el apoyo de Estados
Unidos a Taiwán tenemos el reporte desde
Nueva York
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en Ucrania y ha
comenzaron los referendos de anexión a
Rusia en las autoproclamadas repúblicas
independientes de
así como en los territorios controlados
por Moscú en gerson y zaporiya
recordemos que los comicios son
reconocidos por Moscú Pero no por la
comunidad internacional nuestro equipo
nos reporta desde el terreno
urnas electorales a domicilio es para
votar por el referéndum ahora la puerta
Por favor ya les abro
en Indonesia los combates son frecuentes
y los habitantes dudan en salir para
evitar el abstencionismo todos los
medios son válidos esta supervisoras van
de apartamento en apartamento buena
medida porque tenemos miedo de salir si
hay tiros en la calle y bombas que caen
porque buscar problemas nos quedamos en
casa esta supervisoras van de
apartamento en apartamento la pregunta
formulada está usted de acuerdo sí O no
con entrar a la federación rusa usted
está a favor Por supuesto que sí todo
cambiará encontraremos el buen camino
Rusia nos ayudará con todo las
autoridades se aseguran de que no haya
fraude
cada urna está marcada está sellada y
cerrada herméticamente
siempre está vacía cuando La cogemos y
luego cuando la llevamos al puesto de
votación comparamos el número de firmas
con el número de boletines depositados
así funcionaría idealmente pero no es el
caso de esta mujer que no está inscrita
máximo
menor pero no está aquí frente a
nuestras cámaras votará por ella
[Música]
prisión verdad no yo soy la supervisora
cómo es posible esto nos dirigimos a
pedir explicaciones a la responsable
encargada del puesto de votación
esta mujer votó por su hija
Yo tampoco entiendo Qué pasó está un
poco molesta
comprenda la supervisora son jóvenes Es
la primera vez que hacen ese trabajo de
pronto tuvieron un problema técnico lo
que podemos hacer es anular el voto
haremos la declaración e inscribiremos a
la madre en la lista Porque de todas
maneras ella vive ahí los refugiados Al
otro lado del frente de batalla en la
parte ucraniana no podrán votar las
votaciones No solo se realizan en el don
Bass también en dos regiones del sur de
Ucrania controladas casi en su totalidad
por los rusos estos referendos no tienen
ninguna posibilidad de ser reconocidos
por la comunidad internacional pero para
Vladimir Putin legitiman su operación
militar especial a la vez que ordena una
movilización parcial mientras que los
rusos retroceden en el terreno debido a
la contraofensivo ucraniana
y continuamos con más información
relacionada con la guerra en Ucrania en
Rusia este sábado la fuerza pública ha
detenido a más de 730 personas en las
protestas contra la movilización militar
parcial según la ong ovd info las
manifestaciones se producen en 32
ciudades distintas recordemos que el
decreto anunciado el miércoles por el
presidente Vladimir Putin supone el
envío de 300.000 reservistas al frente
en Ucrania y se trata de el primer
reclutamiento obligatorio en Rusia desde
la Segunda Guerra Mundial la orden llegó
después de que el parlamento ruso la
duma estatal endureciera la represalias
por desertar del ejército
y se cumplen ya ocho días de protestas
en varias ciudades de Irán por la muerte
de maxa Amin las autoridades estatales
informaron que al menos 41 personas han
fallecido en las manifestaciones
incluidos policías mientras que la ong
human right watch reporta 50 muertes
nuestra corresponsal permanente en Irán
Catalina Gómez ángel con el análisis del
movimiento masivo desatado por la muerte
de Amy
desde el 2019 hemos visto como surgen
con mayor frecuencia estas protestas en
Irán pero tal vez ninguna había tenido
el alcance de la que estamos viendo en
este momento no solamente entenderán
donde ayer cientos y cientos de personas
salieron en las calles en diferentes
puntos de la ciudad hasta bien entrada
la noche y se enfrentaban a las fuerzas
de seguridad que trataban de controlarlo
sino en muchas ciudades del resto del
país especialmente en el norte pero
cuentan quienes han participado
anteriormente en estas protestas y las
han analizado que la represión la
esperaban a un mayor cuando volviera al
país el presidente Ibrahim Rey sí que
aceptaba Nueva York en la asamblea
general de las Naciones Unidas cuando
llegó esta mañana se reunió con algunos
de los integrantes o simpatizantes del
gobierno y dijo que había que controlar
estas protestas a lo que estaban siendo
organizadas por los enemigos de Irán
Aunque reconoció que tenía la que había
salido a protestar por la muerte de
maxam Mini esa joven de 22 años que
había sido capturada por la patrulla de
la moral la policía de la moral que
ahora estaban siendo utilizada por los
enemigos de Irán Así que hoy se han
tomado medidas por ejemplo como cerrar
las universidades de Teherán los jóvenes
estudian a través de internet durante
toda la semana argumentan que hay dos
días festivos por la realidad es que
tratan de evitar estas protestas esta
mañana se reunían un grupo de ellos a
las afueras de la Universidad de Teherán
y eran reprimidos y muchos de ellos
capturados y continúa en aumento el
número de personas muertas por el
naufragio de su embarcación frente a las
costas de Siria y los familiares de los
fallecidos se empiezan a identificar la
mayoría de las víctimas eran libaneses y
palestinos
tras el hundimiento del barco que
transportaba decenas de migrantes frente
a las costas de Siria las historias de
familiares de las víctimas mortales
emergen
era el tío de mustafa un migrante
libanés que estaba en la embarcación
junto con sus hijos esto
de vacaciones el partido para cumplir
sus sueños no soñaba con obtener otra
nacionalidad
solo anhelaba con inscribir a sus hijos
en una escuela y poderlos alimentar nada
más el barco que zarpó el 20 de
septiembre el distrito de minigun Líbano
transportaba migrantes de distintas
nacionalidades pero en su mayoría
alibaneses sirios y palestinos que
querían llegar a Europa chipre y las
costas italianas los destinos más
solicitados
la tragedia enluta a toda la zona
geográfica de Levante como a este
campamento de refugiados palestinos en
el norte de Líbano marsharnazar tiene un
familiar desaparecido le reclama el
organismo especial de Naciones Unidas
para los refugiados pale por la tragedia
migratoria en el Mediterráneo
nosotros como palestinos tenemos a la
agencia de Naciones Unidas para los
refugiados palestinos su trabajo era
crear empleos y ayudar al pueblo para el
destino hemos perdido a 30 personas en
el barrio
de Naciones Unidas para los refugiados
palestinos es el único responsable de
este asunto y los líderes palestinos
también deben asumir su responsabilidad
con respecto a su gente
según la ONU más de 5 millones de
palestinos viven actualmente en
campamentos de refugiados se han visto
obligados a abandonar sus hogares debido
a bombardeos israelíes indiscriminados
en la franja de gaza así como la
ocupación de cada vez más territorios en
cisjordania
una gran parte de los palestinos se
refugian en el Líbano que vive una grave
crisis económica que también ha
impulsado a sus ciudadanos a abandonar
su país
este sábado fue el turno de China y
Rusia ante la asamblea general de las
Naciones Unidas en ambos casos el
discurso lo pronunciaron lo respectivos
ministros de exteriores por un lado el
ruso serguéi defendió la invasión de
Ucrania alegó que está basada en la
legítima defensa ante la expansión de la
otan desde el final de la Guerra Fría
por otro lado el ministro de exteriores
chino señaló que Beijing aboga por una
salida pacífica de la guerra en Ucrania
y entre otras cosas condenó el apoyo de
Estados Unidos a Taiwán nuestra
corresponsal en Nueva York mamen sala
con los detalles
sexta jornada en esta asamblea general
número 77 hoy hemos escuchado al líder
de la diplomacia china quien ha dicho
que nos encontramos en un momento de
profundo cambio unos cambios que están
yendo mucho más rápido de lo esperado
todo en un discurso bastante ambiguo
mucho más de lo que escuchamos en el
Consejo de Seguridad por parte de China
entonces allí abocó intensamente por un
diálogo hoy su discurso como digo ha
sido mucho más ambiguo ha dicho que
ningún país debería utilizar su fuerza
para acabar para derrotar a otro ha
dicho que quien empieza una guerra acaba
quemándose fácilmente muy interesante
también ha sido el discurso del ministro
de exteriores rusos sergey labroz quien
ha dicho Quién ha atacado directamente a
Estados Unidos y a sus aliados ha dicho
que Washington quiere convertir a todo
el mundo en su patio trasero y también
hecho hincapié en que la rusofobia de
occidente no tiene precedentes dice que
lo único que quieres acabar con Rusia en
el mapa geopolítico interesante también
lo que no ha mencionado la broad durante
su discurso no ha hecho ningún tipo de
referencia a las amenazas nucleares de
su presidente de esta semana tampoco ha
hecho referencia a ese proceso de
reclutamiento de más de 300.000 hombres
a la desesperada a lo largo del día de
hoy Seguiremos escuchando a otros
líderes mundiales representantes de
otros países como por ejemplo hoy que
hablará esta tarde el representante de
Venezuela
cambiamos de información la tormenta
Fiona golpeó la costa este de Canadá en
Nueva Escocia provocó cortes de luz en
medio millón de hogares Y la devastación
de decenas de edificio mientras a esta
hora no se reportan víctimas humanas
recordemos que antes de llegar a Canadá
el huracán se debilitó hasta convertirse
en ciclón post Tropical según informó el
Centro Nacional de Huracanes de Estados
Unidos a principios de esta semana Fiona
devastó distintas islas del Caribe en
Canadá el fen se dirige ahora al Golfo
de San Lorenzo
Hay demasiadas personas en nuestras
calles viajando tomando fotografías y
simplemente tratando de ver qué está
pasando están interfiriendo con nosotros
tratando de evacuar a las personas y
están interfiriendo y están poniendo sus
propias vidas en peligro y nosotros
estamos diciendote ahora mismo tenemos
postes telefónicos que se están cayendo
alrededor de la comunidad se están
cayendo necesitamos que te quedes en
casa si tu casa es un lugar seguro
Quédate allí si tu casa no es un lugar
seguro trataremos de sacar de trataremos
de ponernos en movimiento y marcharnos
vamos ahora con información de nuestra
región en Ecuador el feminicidio de la
abogada María Belén Bernal ha desatado
manifestaciones en todo el país el
principal sospechoso del crimen es el
esposo de la víctima un general de
policía en paradero desconocido
ante la falta de avances en la
investigación el presidente ecuatoriano
Guillermo lasso pidió la dimisión de su
ministro del interior y de altos mandos
policiales
desde las calles de Ecuador hasta el
gobierno la indignación por el
feminicidio de María Belén Bernal
presuntamente dentro de una institución
policial llevó al presidente a pedir la
renuncia del ministro del interior
Patricio Carrillo y de la cúpula de las
fuerzas de seguridad
es solicitado a los mandos policiales
con él sus cargos a disposición
[Música]
presentando su respectivas Bajas para
evaluar su permanencia en la institución
les quiero pedir perdón porque esto no
debe suceder nunca pero mucho menos en
un edificio público donde se forman
quienes deben protegernos
los acontecimientos dan conmocionado a
un país entero María Belén Bernal fue a
visitar a su esposo un Coronel de la
policía a una escuela de la institución
en Quito desde ese mismo día el 11 de
septiembre desapareció hasta que su
cuerpo fue encontrado en las
inmediaciones del edificio con señales
de asfixia las primeras investigaciones
señalan a su esposo Germán Cáceres
prófugo desde hace días como el
principal sospechoso del feminicidio y
cuentan además que una docena de agentes
ahora bajo investigación escucharon los
gritos de auxilio de la víctima sin
hacer nada
la madre de María Belén Bernal denunció
a la policía y al estado
mi hija es una víctima ella murió dentro
de la escuela de superior de policía por
lo tanto es un crimen de estado señores
es un crimen de estado mi hija no puede
quedar impune No más
un grito de Justicia que desde hace días
se replica en masivas manifestaciones en
todo el país
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en francés 24 y Francia
24.com
[Música]